all that conversation and  you know my respect for reggie and ray  guys who  set the bar for what it meant to be a  sharpshooter to have the longevity as  well  [Music]  for me i've tried to own that in my  journey in terms of  you know  range volume efficiency  all those things go into it so i pride  myself on shooting a high percentage i  pride myself on  allowing that to help us win games  and now i can pride myself on the  longevity of getting to that number that  that ray set and hopefully pushing it to  a number that nobody can reach we'll see  what happens but that's something that  the balance of volume and  efficiency for me is  the standard that i wanted to set and  i never want to call myself the greatest  shooter until i got this record so  i'm comfortable saying that now